luego de una década de investigación
científica sobre la felicidad en el perú
y en cuatro continentes una de las cosas
que más nos llama la atención es la
increíble capacidad humana para soñar
para desarrollar estrategias y dedicarse
por años y décadas para cumplir esos
sueños sin embargo algunos de estos
sueños van a llevar a la felicidad y
otros a la infelicidad van a ser una
cosa magnífica y unas pésimas ideas para
la sociedad consecuentemente una
pregunta sustancial es te has puesto a
pensar cuáles son los sueños que están
dirigiendo tu vida
esa pregunta se la hicieron hace más de
20 años
richard ryan jett decide la universidad
de rochester a propósito del sueño
estadounidense y encontraron que
fundamentalmente era el tener dinero o
fama belleza etcétera pero las pocas
personas que alcanzaban este sueño
estadounidense terminaban viviendo una
pesadilla en materia de bienestar
subjetivo la salud mental y física se
deterioraba y eran las personas que
reportaban ser más infelices que
aquellas personas que no alcanzaban ese
sueño estadounidense
y esto es coherente con los estudios
mundiales de felicidad que introduce en
una medida de percepción subjetiva de
felicidad el new economics foundation
quizás tenga el estudio más famoso en
este en esta línea y podemos ver en
color rojo los países más infelices y
miserables del planeta que junto con
áfrica subshariana podemos ver a los
países del autodenominado primer mundo y
si vemos en color verde amarillo y medio
mostaza con aquí vamos a ver que la
región más feliz del mundo es américa
latina y el caribe en este contexto tras
el financiamiento de los últimos años de
una consultora del ipe bienestar y
productividad hemos estudiado cuál es
ese sueño que está detrás de esta
felicidad latinoamericana y es
fundamentalmente la familia y los amigos
detrás de esta fuente de felicidad
existe una historia
que está escrita en el cableado de
nuestro cerebro cableado que se ha ido
formando en los últimos miles y millones
de años nosotros no somos una especie
que tiene alas para volar ni rayos láser
ni grandes dientes de sable lo único que
tenemos es una extraordinaria capacidad
de organizarlos fundamentalmente estar
unidos en familia con los amigos
armando tribus y estar dentro de la
tribu era cuestión de vida o muerte y
estar fuera de la tribu lo opuesto a si
nuestro cerebro se fue cableando para
generar un circuito virtuoso que aún se
vive en nuestra región cuando tenemos un
problema se activa el sistema del estrés
y circula por nuestro sistema nervioso
una sustancia que se llama cortisol que
luego va a tocarle la puerta a la
oxitocina para pedir la ayuda de los
amigos y de la familia cuando
encontramos esta ayuda se va a regular
el cortisol
va a bajar nuestro estrés y se van a
producir opiáceos lo cual quiere decir
que nos va a generar felicidad este
efecto nos va a durar algunas semanas o
algunos días pero en américa latina
siempre a dar un nuevo problema que
generará estrés encontraremos a la
familia y a los amigos que estarán ahí
para ayudarnos y tendremos un círculo
drogó virtuoso natural sin efecto
secundario que podría arruinar parte
importante de la industria farmacéutica
y del narcotráfico
qué maravilloso cambiado cerebral se
protagoniza aún en américa latina pero
en el mundo autodenominado desarrollado
cuando tienen un problema te van a decir
leave me alone déjame solo no van a
buscar ayuda y cuando quieran buscar la
ya no habrá costumbre y no los van a
ayudar lo cual la activa un sistema que
va a generar más depresión y más
infelicidad esto esta oxitocina
inherentemente se convierte en un
neurotransmisor de la felicidad con una
un efecto duradero y con un bajísimo
nivel de efectos secundarios más
concretamente cuál es el sueño peruano
es el de una familia próspera educada y
elegantemente moderna que quiere decir
elegante va a variar de segmento en
segmento esto es parte de los estudios
que hacemos con el grupo de
investigación bienestar cultura y
desarrollo de la universidad cátolica
permitan rápidamente presentarles a
nuestro talentoso dedicado y
de gente que fundamentalmente buenas
personas y que de chile en china nos
estamos recorriendo la felicidad y la
infelicidad del perú bueno esta idea de
una familia próspera educada y elegante
sólo si puede ser una idea en abstracto
interesante pero en la práctica tiene un
lado torcido porque la educación cuando
hemos estado profundizando es
básicamente tener cartón
no no es la gente no busca reforzar sus
valores su identidad y adquirir nuevas
competencias es el cartón entonces eso
explica porque no solamente en el perú
sino es un problema regional existe un
tema de plagio espeluznante en los
exámenes se copian monografías completas
etcétera salen de la universidad con su
cartón y no van a competir por
competencias sino tendrán que buscar a
un amigo oa un familiar para que lo sabe
entrar y dentro de la organización le
deberán favores a ellos y se irán
generando unas mafias algo lleras
alucinantes pero a la argolla se
tropezara más temprano que tarde con
otra argolla y se generará la guerra de
todos contra todos en perjuicio de la
productividad de la empresa y en
perjuicio de la productividad nacional
entonces es el lado torcido va a generar
que vayan creciendo los temas de
corrupción de conseguir plata a la buena
esto ha sido corroborado con el estudio
más grande que se ha hecho hasta la
fecha en el perú sobre la identidad
nacional en el ámbito de todo el
territorio hecho por el instituto
integración del grupo de rpp con los
cuales participamos en el análisis y hay
dos identidades la del peruano
respetuoso y culto pero oculto no como
erudición sino culto como de buenas
costumbres y el peruano desubicado
qué es pandémico el desubicado es un
peruano florero agradable etcétera pero
que en el fondo no está interesado en
generar una relación recíproca de mutua
ayuda o mutuo respeto si no está a la
expectativa de aprovechar la oportunidad
y cuando el otro progresa va a sentirse
miserable con un sentimiento muy
difundido que es la envidia y va a
contraatacar metiéndole clave al logro
del otro
dentro de largo ya no tanto pero también
un poco iba a practicar el deporte
nacional que es el chisme entonces en
estas circunstancias también observen
que vivir en provincias y tener menor
nivel educativo aumenta la posibilidad
de ser respetuoso y reduce la
posibilidad de ser desubicado no esto
tiene que ver también con un proceso
bien ancestral entonces en qué momento
se jodió el perú ya la ciencia tiene
varias respuestas y uno de los momentos
jodidos de nuestra historia es cuando
los migrantes de las pequeñas
comunidades tradicionales llegan a las
grandes ciudades como lima y son
recibidos con una discriminación
agresiva cuando ocurre eso se activa un
fenómeno denominado exclusión social y
esta exclusión social va a activar el
área del cerebro de mayor alerta que es
la del dolor físico
distintos estudios
los más prestigiosos y recientes pueden
señalar que cuando nosotros somos
excluidos socialmente somos choteados
somos marginados
somos denominados chorros de [ __ ]
vamos a tener las mismas activaciones
del dolor físico y eso que va a generar
va a generar primero un corte en el
sistema de la empatía es decir yo ya no
me voy a poner en el en el zapato del
otro y consecuentemente ya ni lo voy a
saludar ni voy a hacer condescendiente y
pasado cierto punto de discriminación
voy a disfrutar que le vaya mal al otro
entonces aquí vamos a observar que
tenemos un problema muy complicado en
nuestra historia y es algo que se está
retroalimentando porque va generando una
interacción desubicada en donde la gente
se pone cada vez más barreras a la
empatía y tenemos una dinámica callejera
social laboral e interpersonal más allá
de la argolla
si esto es correcto que va a ocurrir va
a aumentar la oferta educativa como
negocio no como vocación y la educación
va a estar en crisis paralelamente al
crecimiento del número de universidades
e institutos tecnológicos etcétera habrá
un crecimiento del consumo estaremos
orgullosos de que batimos récord en
importación de autos y especialmente en
el segmento de lujo pero estaremos más
los casos más patanes y más desubicados
en la interacción cotidiana entonces la
pregunta fundamental aquí es cómo evitar
que el perú se joda más
para responder en parte esta
interrogante podemos buscar cuáles son
los lugares más felices de verdad de
nuestro territorio y podríamos comenzar
con las magníficas caletas de pescadores
pequeñas zonas donde todavía la
actividad turística e industrial es
marginal allí las familias van a
trabajar unidas protagonizando los
valores del trabajo de la unión y las
familias no van a ser respetadas porque
tengan más plata televisor más grande
sino por la calidad del trabajo y de la
unión de la familia en ese sentido
también las magníficas pequeñas
comunidades tradicionales en los andes'
en donde además del trabajo familiar
existe un excelente trabajo comunitario
en donde todos los vecinos cooperan para
sembrar y cosechar la chacra de un
miembro de la comunidad y al otro día
todos irán a otra chacra y así habrá un
trabajo de familias
comunidad y de colectividad en donde
todos van sumando y adicionalmente las
magníficas comunidades amazónicas en
donde se guarda un místico equilibrio
con la naturaleza
paradójicamente estas son las familias
que cuando van en búsqueda del progreso
de una mejor educación para sus hijos
van a ser las familias discriminadas un
amazónico que ha viajado por ocho horas
para llegar a una escuela será el
chuncho incluso marginado por la propia
escuela
un andino que llega a la ciudad será
soleado por otro que vive a 400 metros
más cerca del nivel del mar y también
será marginado por aquel de su propia
comunidad que llegó un año antes y así
dejará de ser el magnífico señor
comunero que por ser honrado trabajar y
respetar las costumbres será respetado
como un ciudadano para convertirse en el
cholo de [ __ ] esto de alguna u otra
forma va a ir generando que las personas
se den más la cuenta que eso magnífico
que esos valores esa felicidad no es
buena y que hay que adoptar un patrón
moderno y así se compran la gran estafa
que es
el ideal del cartón y de la plata a la
buena oa la mala así resulta fundamental
reforzar los valores peruanos no machu
picchu ni las niñas de nazca sino esos
magníficos valores comunidades de los
abuelos y de los padres de los de los
muchos de los que estamos aquí presentes
pero integrarlos a la modernidad para
cumplir esos dos sueños el de mantener
una buena identidad pero integrarnos en
el mundo más contemporáneo ya propósito
de esto una pregunta interesante es cuál
es el lugar más feliz del perú moderno
hicimos un estudio en las grandes
ciudades en el perú y encontramos que el
sistemáticamente uno de los lugares más
felices era el valle del mantaro y el
valle del mantaro no tiene la magnífica
arquitectura cusqueña ni el paisaje
esplendoroso de la cordillera de los
andes si no tiene huancaínos tiene
huancas
el one k tiene un equilibrio del trabajo
y la diversión trabaja duro pero se
juegue a duro también no hay un solo día
en el calendario anual donde no hay
alguna fiesta patronal en el valle del
mantaro en segundo lugar es un chulo
power no es un cholo acomplejado que es
ingeniero perdón que hayas venido a mi
pueblito feo no chino ven y tómate dos
cervezas conmigo
en tercer lugar
son comunidades de un elevado sentido
meritocrático cualquier joven huancaíno
sabe que respetando las tradiciones
ayudando a la familia a los vecinos
trabajando duro teniendo éxito va a ser
reconocido como un señor ciudadano a
diferencia por ejemplo de la ciudad del
cusco uno de los lugares más infelices
del perú en donde tienen que tener
además una familia respetable y así no
van a haber nuevos ricos solamente van a
aumentar los nuevos pobres entonces todo
esto va configurando la necesidad no el
lujo ni la opción la necesidad de
emprender un plan nacional un plan
nacional de no menos de tres años por no
decir siete años en donde el gobierno
los medios de comunicación la sociedad
civil la cooperación internacional cada
uno de nosotros aquí presentes esté
involucrado para que para rescatar los
valores tradicionales
e integrarlos en la modernidad y por qué
es importante esto por dos sencillas
razones primero porque así vamos a
lograr nuestra felicidad personal y la
felicidad de la familia y en segundo
lugar porque así evitaremos que este
país se siga jodiendo
[Aplausos]
[Música]